as in my home when the wind took the
fire to the O'Briens I knew I need to do
that thing that people wonder about
their whole life decide what should take
from a burning building objects memories
items that are tangible
these are our artifacts our scarves
emotional physical we live our lives and
ask what do we leave behind
don't you tell me how you came across
this beautiful green seems valuable I
don't know about that but it is to me
though
what do you want from your grandfather
still be something box Bluff letters
diaries lives lived I raised my family
here and you know what
miss Hong you can tell everybody that I
died as I lived my childhood home you're
a puzzle little bro
it's just hard for me to understand what
this all means to you this is your space
I might things are not the same as they
were before things have changed you
don't have to go back to that house
second era
the house is the last place you saw her
every memory she has it's in here
love it maybe all you have left
you
you